there's a lot of news that talk about
but it all feels a little trivial in
comparison to the current state of
things which is why I think it's
important to first and foremost
mentioned play for all which is a
multi-week charity event raising money
for not only people who are fighting on
the front line for kovat 19 but also for
black lives matter
starting today from 12 p.m. to 2 p.m. Pt
we're going to be having a bunch of
special guests in an effort to raise
money for these causes people like a lot
of Pierce hey-zeus here's toast Troy
Baker Danny O'Dwyer and a whole bunch of
others now we're also going to be having
a lot of exclusive content alongside
these charities but it's just as
important we put this first and foremost
at the center so you know where we stand
ok on to the news which includes
Playstation Pokemon and Sega I'm Kurt
and Davina this is safe State that's
Monday June 1st so a bridgely
playstation was supposed to have a big
old stream this thursday on june 4th but
sony just put out an announcement that
they're postponing it and for good
reason we've decided to postpone the
playstation 5 event scheduled for June
4th while we understand gamers worldwide
are excited to see PS 5 games we do not
feel that right now is a time for
celebration and for now we want to stand
back and allow more important voices to
be heard as a now there isn't a date
lined up but that's ok it'll come when
it comes
pokemon sword and shield details are
coming soon and when I mean soon I mean
tomorrow Tuesday June 2nd there's going
to be a bunch of details revealed at 6
a.m. PT 9 a.m. ET and 2 p.m. BT British
time now we know that I love armors is
coming out sometime this month so it's a
Super Bowl we're gonna get a release
date tomorrow this is also one of two
expansions the other being Crown tundra
we're gonna be giving a new legendary
Pokemon named cub foo and Giganta max
forms for all the star pokemon now it's
likely we'll have a lot to talk about
tomorrow so make sure you come back to
see pers I handle all that jazz on
savestate looks like sega's preparing
for something big
or without III to announce it Komatsu
reports the Japanese technology
journalist Zhen Shan Ishikawa teased a
huge scoop for Famitsu magazine
Nishikawa says the scoop is comparable
to wires exclusive ps5 details the rumor
says it involves Microsoft but it's
important to note that Nishikawa never
mentioned Microsoft in his teases now
rumors aside giving you Kuzon like a
dragon's prominent presence with the
Xbox series acts this kind of checks out
but we'll find out on June 4th when that
magazine issue is released PlayStation
five news continues to trickle out
including that PS 5 games are going to
cost more to develop Sony Interactive
Entertainment CEO Jim Ryan told game
industry adopt is that he believes PS 5
games will cost more to develop saying
quote I think to the extent that
technology enables the graphics side of
it to become more interesting and
lifelike the games will become slightly
more human intensive and capital
intensive to produce he also said we
don't see it as being a massive increase
Sony also wants to start a faster ship
between the ps4 to PS 5 what that means
and how they do it we don't know yet
there's a lot of unanswered questions
with the PlayStation 5 so we'll find out
when we find out alright that's all we
got for today thanks for joining me
there's that and a whole bunch more at
GameSpot comm so be sure to go there and
stay up the date with all the gaming
news including the play for all schedule
don't forget about it it's good it's
important all right I'm Curtin Davina be
sure to come back tomorrow for Persia be
nice be cool black lives matter see you
later
[Music]
[Music]